oh my goodness
why she's here
did you tell her she has something to
say
no she keep you have something to have
something to say
layla has no idea about our plans
at this point i am completely
overweighting and
as his girlfriend i'm ready for shakib
to make me a priority
and i'm ready for shakib to make the
decision to move out now
um i wanted to tell you that i want to
what like
why are you stuttering just tell her
directly that's the issue with you
look her in the eyes and tell her you
are talking like that in front of me
bye emily have a goodbye now bye
get out of here no i'm not going
anywhere you're just ruling my
day with my son today i'm done what are
you doing i'm not talking about it
no even i don't want to see you your
face
should keep us moving out with me
we're going to do it in my dead body
he's going to stay with me for the rest
of his life
she's crazy i'm the mother i am the one
brought she keep
in the war so
she came is not going to move up no
this is the next step of our
relationship i'm not listening
to you the reality is i i do eventually
want to move out and i didn't no
not eventually now
tell your mom now
say it now why are you hesitant again
hold on
but what
i'm having second thoughts about moving
out because i just don't want this i
don't want to move
out with all this stress i want to give
everyone a chance to just take a break
breathe in
you know give them all some time to
actually digest that we're moving out
together me and emily
yeah even though i promise emily that i
will be moving out just a little time is
all we need for my mom to accept it